Hasani soma a man I've been a tortured
because everybody in this town is the
self torture torture
the last five years Greece has
experienced a communitarian crisis that
we haven't felt since the Second World
War especially the youth felt like
there's no future
we stopped dreaming about our lives in a
few days a new left government will be
elected and we hope we all hope that
syriza along with the people will give a
new hope a new life cycle to the good
Society
this is an evidence of where the crisis
a lot of salt small salt in the city
center happened close as you can see all
other uses have been closed but except
from this one I know a lot of people
that they are in need they try to resell
everything they already have in order to
I don't know to even go to the hospital
you see all these buildings with great
architectural value but they are almost
collapsing I mean here you are going to
meet a person a friend of ours that has
been really excited by the crisis
yes escalator it feels like it feels
like every day is the same
there's no way to to chase what you want
from from from life life is short
there is a generation here waiting and
waiting for an opportunity to be given
and you can't live like that you have to
act she remembers we believe that we are
not the left of the fall the fail but we
are the left to win and it's our time to
win
the 2008 financial crisis hit Europe
Greece has been bailed out twice by the
EU its central bank and the IMF in
exchange